hi everyone
uh yeah thank you for inviting me thanks
for the organizers
great pleasure to be here uh yes i will
be giving the second part of this uh
circularity-based io uh series of talks
and this is joint work with rafael pass
so recall that
um as julia explained uh
i'll explain our work with the following
in light of the following blueprint
to get io you can go through
um split fhe that gives xio that
can be bootstrapped for you okay and
remember recall that
split fhe it's an fft
uh so if you have an encryption of a
message
you can evaluate a function on it and
you get an fh in encryption of the
function f evaluated on the message
uh and you can release essentially think
of it as a randomness so like a hint
for this particular evaluated ciphertext
which has to be succeed
its size doesn't depend on the size of
the output of the function
for them and it reveals only f of n
essentially roughly speaking okay so
we've dually covered it this is the
abstraction
uh i'll be using in the stock as well
okay
uh right so um
what is our result basically we believe
from two assumptions
first the standard learning with their
assumption and second
a strong circular conjecture with
respect to a
standard lwe based encryptions
let me explain a little bit more uh what
i mean by
this circular conjecture so in general
circular security
uh say that if you have uh that security
is
going to be preserved in the presence of
an encryptive key cycle
for instance you have two encryption
schemes a black one and a blue one
and you consider in particular semantic
security of the black scheme
a natural assumption is to say well okay
this
semantic security is going to be
preserved even in the presence of
these encryptions here so here it's an
encryption of the blue key under the
black scheme
in here encryption of the black key and
there's a blue skew
right you can think of cycle of
different sizes
right and as i said the conjecture is to
say well for natural schemes
semantic security is going to be
preserved in the presence of an
encrypted key cycle
public conjecture is too strong of a
name for the i mean
too formal of a name for this but maybe
you can say uh
heuristic heuristic yes maybe it's a
better name because it's not really a
formal conjecture
right design principle or heuristic
maybe it's a better name okay
yeah right so i said natural schemes
because
uh this heuristic we know is not
true for some particular schemes there
are some some skills that
are semantically secure
but not circularly secure however all
the counter examples that we know of
are contrived they are specifically
designed
circular security to fail and it's a
reasonably widespread
um assumption to say that uh for natural
schemes
uh this security is preserved
and the most uh famous example of this
is probably
bootstrapping by the gentry
which is the way that's used to obtain
unleveled fhe
right um in a level
refers to the fact that you can evaluate
arbitrary depth circuits and not
without any a priori bound okay if we
create a storm
uh here in this case a cycle of size one
actually
and for this application semantic
security surprises
but in general you may consider you may
want to consider different security
options for example
i don't know like ccga security cage
resilience and so on
so this leads to the natural strength
setting of this
heuristic say for any natural schemes
and any natural security notion
this security notion is going to be
preserved in the presence of an
encrypted key cycle
this is a strong circular heuristic that
we'll be using
right so now let me rephrase our result
a little bit more precisely
we can get io from lwe and this strong
circular heuristic
with respect to a new security notion
which is which we call shielded
randomness leakage security srl
which roughly speaking involves an
adversary
that gets a challenge ciphertext and uh
some information about the randomness
used to produce these ciphertexts
i'll be more specific later
and uh with respect to uh two
standard encryption schemes so the
well-known gentry sehate weathersfhi
from the homomorphic encryption scheme
and a packed variant of reagan
encryption scheme
both of which are known to be secure
under lwe
assumption
uh more in detail we first show that gsw
is srl secure from the lwb assumption
and then we show that if you assume this
sls security of gsw is preserved in the
presence
of a dsw and partridge f key cycle
and you also hq lw then you get io
so now let me explain what several
security is in a little bit more detail
so you have an fhe which encrypt bits so
you have a bunch of encryptions of bits
you can automatically evaluate the
function f you'll get
fhe of f m so basically
the homomorphism says that when you act
on the ciphertext
it will act on the plain text but it
will also act on the
randomness you can think of this
encryption
as uh an encryption under a randomness r
sub f
because it depends on the function f and
you can actually compute
this r sub f directly from the original
messages to the original randomness
and you can open this evaluated
ciphertext
using this r sub f to recover f of l
right uh so this is
property we refer to as randomness or
morpheme and gsw satisfies this property
so once you have a ciphertext you can
decrypt it usually as usual with the
secret key or you can open it
with this evaluated randomness and that
doesn't require the secret key
what is srl leakage essentially it's a
shielded variant
of this evaluated randomness r sub f for
some functions
the first thing i want to say is since
rf
allows to open the ciphertext to recover
f of m
and this is also true for shielding
variant of rf
we need to restrict the class of
function f for which we reveal such
leakage
if we want to hope to prove any
meaningful security notion
we need to hide some information about
the message and if you can recover f of
for any f there's no way so we will
restrict our attention
to functions f which for now are called
predictable and be more specific later
on
think of them as constant functions it's
a bit more complicated than that but
basically
functions with output can be revealed
without harming security
and a second comment i want to make is
that
even if you restrict to let's say
constant function revealing rf is not
okay
uh you need a shielded variant of ours
you need to yeah all right um why is it
okay
it's actually broken it's it's not known
to be well it's it's insecure if you
give out just rf so you need to show it
again i'll be more specific later all
right
uh and so with the shield again we can
prove
this is achieved by gsw from lwb
all right um just a notation i will
actually it's convenient for me to write
vectors like this it does don't be
confused into thinking that this is a
string encryption it is a bit encryption
gsw is a bit encryption
it just means it's a concatenation of
many base encryptions all right
all right so now let me give you the
security gate which defines a certain
security
uh so far it's just a neat cpa security
game
that we all know with the differences
that
actually make it explicit i make
explicit the fact that
here's the adversary chooses not just
one pair of messages but many of
them all right and he gets back many
challenges i context
this is important because the randomness
leakage
will be on all the randomness used by
all
encryptions to get this leakage
the adversary will interact with an
oracle leakage oracle
and it goes like this first the oracle
sends a fresh
fh encryption of zero
upon which the adversary can choose a
function f and a prediction alpha
and if the prediction is correct which
means f on
the challenge plaintext is equal to
alpha which essentially
means the adversary already knows the
output
then it's actually okay to give him back
the actual leakage
which is r sub f computed as i showed
you before
so it's like homomorphic it's evaluated
randomness
completely from this guy here plus
this r star
so if you only look at the leakage
essentially it's rf
with a one-time band padded with r star
so this looks good this means no
information whatsoever
will be licked about rf however a
this r star is some information about
our stars you feel
when uh through the fh encryption of
zero
because it uses our star as a randomness
okay so this is not equivalent
between cpa and
if the prediction is not correct
then the leakage is just bought and
in that case we say the adversary fails
uh this can be done many times but yeah
sorry and at the end the atmosphere has
to guess
which message were encrypted okay and he
wins if
he guesses correctly and if he didn't
fail if he didn't make
the oracle output
and we say a scheme is a serial secure
if
no efficient adversary can win with
probability significantly better than
one half
and recall that we prove gsw is the
serial secured under lw
all right now to get io
we actually need a circular circular
variant of this
which looks like this it's essentially
the same thing except now we have this
encrypted
key cycle so not only do we have
uh an fh encryption of the challenge
message but we also have an encryption
of the
blue secret key and there's a black
scheme and an encryption of the black
secret key and there's a blue screen
right cycle of size 2.
and the evaluated randomness that's part
of the leakage
will touch the randomness used to
encrypt mb but also escape r
everything all the randomness right so
now the
right so that changes the condition like
this
all right essentially apart from that
this is the same game
and uh we show that
assume lwe and assume gsw
fhe and patrick f are circularly srl
secure according to this definition here
then you get io
yes just to play the devil spark
so you started by saying that it's very
hard to come up with something which is
not circular secure and i totally agree
you have to work hard
how hard it is to come up with something
that violates this security definition
well the only example we know are the
ones that
are uh used to prove some
uh the one that's uh are used to prove
uh
beats encryption so that it will be
using lockable discussion or like
if you didn't compare this is only what
we know
and even yeah in terms of this kind of
test this this
this thing seems to satisfy the the
i don't know the heuristic suggestion
from your first slide like
that i mean you you believe that this
thing is uh
as a i don't know as believable as
some standard psychic security
well so there are some differences uh
it's not exactly it's more sophisticated
notion but sure like the reason we
believe security
like this i i think it fits the general
design
principle in the sense that i would be
surprised like
uh the only counter example i can think
of at least
uh are are highly artificial
essentially as artificial as for beating
encryption
even though the ssl notion is new uh
right i would say
i don't know like the philosophically
yeah the
the gap between yeah i don't know like
uh oh okay okay
okay don't have anything to say yeah so
and benny uh purely it could also be
like somewhat harder to actually get a
counter example because to get a counter
example
you actually need to get a scheme that
is srl secure
right so your starting scheme needs to
be several secure
and not circular secured yeah whereas to
get a counter example for semantical
security
it's enough to get a scheme that's
semantically secure so here you actually
need to start off with
so really it's only one of the counter
examples for
circular security that works for srl the
most recent one by
daniel and on based on lockable
obfuscation the earlier ones we don't
know how to modify
so less of the counter examples for
circuit security apply for this
notion because your premier you start
off with more
yeah so just to expand i think it would
also be interesting
and you there also it doesn't seem
trivial uh to have counter examples
which
are plausibly circularly secure but
broken with srl security
but there also we do not seem to have uh
clean examples that do that even
assuming io i mean
maybe one can do that but probably one
can do that
uh but it seems hard to come up with uh
directly
like the way the way i see it you know
this kind of uh
like i think that the world shielding is
kind of misleading this is basically
correlated with this right
once you put this all star
on the table then it means that you
encrypt the two things under content at
randomness
and i think that the same heuristic
feeling that we have about circular
security we could have
with respect to discoverated randomness
kind of games
what's not clear to me is that what
happens when you mix all these things
together plus some more fism
whether it makes a i don't know makes
the assumptions
less believable but i guess that we
don't know i don't know
it's also another thing is i'm just
confused a little bit by this
uh security game uh the adversary
doesn't win
at all by the e is it the case that
uh if the adversary sends the message a
pair f alpha then the adversary must be
convinced that
f of mb has to equal alpha
because otherwise they fail because if
so then
why wouldn't the adversary
why doesn't it just reduce to the case
that adversary always just use f as the
constant zero function
and the alpha is the zero value and then
basically all the diversity does you
just get a bunch of uh
encryption of our star plus
i guess the point is that this is our f
our f plus r star so yeah that's the
thing that someone confuses
uh it wouldn't work it wouldn't be
sufficient to build io
if you had actual constant function that
way i said you can think of them as
constant function
but they're not uh
so even though the output is predictable
it's
alpha it's known by the adversary
the behavior of f will depend on its
input
in particular if f is given an input
something that doesn't contain a sk bar
it will not output the same thing as if
it actually is fed with something that
contains sk bar
and i think this is why maybe leno is
going to mention it
this is why this type of assumption is
qualitatively different because
so f is not constant that's the first
point i wanted to make second point is
also
you cannot actually switch uh as is
sometimes done
uh fhe like basically a cycle of keys
it's an encrypted key cycle soon two
encryptions of zero this you cannot do
it uh
because for the function we care about
to go like sayo and you can detect
you can you will basically lose
correctness i'm not sure it's exactly
answering
your question but i think it's a good
point to make okay okay i think it
makes yeah but maybe i understand better
as you as you continue
so so just regarding your last point so
we have to interact
so if you go back to the heuristic where
actually this is also based on
discussion that i had with twigger
so i could i could rephrase your
heuristic in the following way
i could say for normal schemes the
adversary cannot even tell whether there
was a second law there was no cycle and
this is the reason why it should
remain secure and this kind of argument
you cannot apply here right
yes because here you could decide yes
exactly this kind of argument you cannot
apply we don't need it that's also the
thing
right but yes you cannot apply this
argument so it's like a different
setting
it's the slightly it's slightly
different qualitatively different yes
but technically uh assuming
sll security is preserved in the
presence of an encrypted key cycle as
rafael said it's incomparable
technically incomparable to assuming
that semantic security is preserved
in the presence of a critical cycle you
start off with a stronger security and
you end up with stronger security
but there are subtleties for sure that
uh some of the intuitive
nutrition you may have on circular
security will not
actually hold here
yeah good all right i
just maybe okay that's maybe too much
but like you said that
i don't know uh that you can think of it
as a correlation interactability a
correlation type of assumption like
saying
well so the thing is even in the plane
uh several security you have this
correlation right you have this
this thing here and uh and that guy here
which are correlated
and this you can actually prove under
lwe so the gap is
between when you add up this circular
thing otherwise you can actually prove
very good okay uh
all right so the reason yeah so with
we think it's an actual security notion
and let me show you
uh with an application of plain circular
security srl
not circuit sorry i say plane circular i
mean plane no circular
all right uh so an application where
this leakage can show up
like a toy example so you have database
of private
record let's say bank record
and you trust alice the third party to
encrypt it for you and put it in the
cloud it's fetch encrypted
analysts will also compute an unfetching
encryption of xero
and then at some point someone asked you
to prove a statement on your database
for example that you have enough money
on your bank account
and without of course you don't want to
reveal the exact amount of money you
have
so you will ask addis to produce a zero
knowledge book
analysts can just send the extra leakage
as a proof
short it doesn't depend on the size of
the complexity of the statement
and everybody can verify that uh this
proof is
called we can verify this proof by fhe
evaluating this encryption here
and then adding the encryption of zero
and then opening the result with the sll
leakage
and checking the checking the result so
this is sound as long as
the encryption produced by alice are
proper
and without going into the details
because actually it will require
simulation based serial security notion
zero knowledge is achieved by several
security right
essentially uh the the slow allocation
only reveals
f of database
all right uh and ice can provide
many proofs and the online phase is
super short it's just a small linkage
right and alice has to pre-compute
all these encryptions of zero
all right so just like uh to give you a
sense where where this is sort of can
show up
okay so again um just repeating
our results to be an io a from this
assumption
and i'll focus on the rest of the stock
on the second part
namely showing io from
the lwb plus this circular sl security
um and uh we build upon
the uh bdg m20a
um split after we do not actually be the
speed
but for the stock i will explain it
using the abstractions
that you explained all right so
remember uh the way they build a split
fhe is
start off with any fhe
and evaluate a function on it then if
there's a randomness of the fhe is too
large
and it's also insecure to release it so
that's not going to be a good hit
however there are some lhe they're not
fooling momofix they're only linearly
homomorphic
for which we have small randomness
first and second decrypting an fhe is
nothing else but
computing linear operation and rounding
so at least we can perform the linear
operation of the decryption
under the hood of the led not the
rounding
so you can perform a partial decryption
like a proxy or encrypt you turn this
fhe
into an lhe and because you cannot round
you will have some fhe decryption noise
and as julia explained we know that
now okay we could release the randomness
of this guy now it is short
great we have succinctness but it's
still insecure
because it will also reveal in
particular this noise this fh decryption
and we know that's breaking security so
that's not what they do
they say okay now suppose you have this
magical oracle
which anytime it's invoked spits out a
fresh
le key encryption of a smudging notes
sli now that'd be great because now you
can just add this
to that and now you release the
the randomness of the addition
so this thing here it is succeed and it
is actually secure
they prove it because essentially uh
this matching noise well is doing gonna
basically
erase all the information it's gonna
smudge this fhe decryption
obviously right and the challenge is to
implement this
this oracle right there's no such thing
as a
an oracle that spits out lh encryption
smudging noise so they have to create
them and this is where the heuristic
begins so what do they do
as uh i'm basically explaining uh
uh what you already mentioned but i
think it's good for uh
to make sure uh you start out with a
random oracle that picks out random bits
right that okay
and because lhe ciphertext sound tense
any bit string is essentially an
encryption
of course uh it's not going to be an
encryption
of uh something structured it's going to
be an encryption of something uniform
which is not useful as such
so uh their idea was to actually proxy
encrypted
basically you want to round this uniform
message ui
and make it smaller you cannot run this
lhc we know that but you can round this
fhe
so you turn this lh encryption into an
fhe
that requires a key cycle by the way
then you round
you can do whatever you want it's an ffg
and then you turn it back again to an
lhe
so basically since you cannot have fresh
lh encryption as maginot you engineer it
yourself you craft it
you create it and you get an lh
encryption that's not fresh
but that's okay of a noise that is of
the right size it's a smudging size it's
not uniform
you still get some meaningful
information but you can smudge
the annoying fh decryption noise event
but when you do this when you do this
proxy encryption again you will create
an fh decryption noise again and
so it's going around a little bit in
circle because you essentially create a
symmetric
noise to erase an fph decryption noise
but doing so create
an extra fhe decryption noise
right and the problem is these actually
are dependent they are correlated
statistically
but yeah it is in practice we don't
really know how to exploit these
correlations
right uh and so eureka realistically
it's just
it's okay you there's that right there's
no way to break this in practice
in fact the paper they even show extra
uh like heuristics to to make it even
harder to
potentially exploit all right so this is
uh what i did
and our work was basic will basically be
to instantiate this
uh this thing with a probable secure
with the security proof under the
circular satellite section
all right this is our contribution
so the first thing we'll do that's not
too hard is just replace the random
oracle by ucrs
we can afford it because we know xio is
pre-processing is sufficient
first observation quite simple a second
more important thing
is to say the problem is this
correlation right the fact that fhe
decryption noise depends on
the evaluated time text they are
correlated
so what we do is refresh the fha
evaluation
this is common if you want to obtain
circuit privacy if you want
the idea is to get an fh evaluation
which looks like a fresh
encryption so that's great that's
exactly what we want we break
correlations
however uh this
evaluation now becomes randomized and
it's important to reveal the random
coins that are used
to refresh the fhe ciphertext because
you want the person that object and the
person that runs the infestation to
agree
they want to actually compute the same
ciphertext so they can actually
recover the output so you need actually
to reveal all these random coins
now it may seem a little bit dangerous
you refresh but you reveal the random
code used to refresh
and uh so this alone will not be enough
right it's not magical however it will
be good it will be useful
uh anyway to locally break the
correlation and then
you can essentially conclude the proof
with this srl
circular security assumption that i
showed you before
all right combination of these two will
actually provide proof
uh so this is how it looks we've
replaced
the random rocket by a crs which
contains a bunch of
nh encryption of uniform noise as before
we proxy we encrypt them we round
and now we refresh that's a new thing to
break the correlation
and now okay we will have a fresh fh
encryption that's great
which means if the fh encryption is
fresh the resulting noise
is also fresh and therefore it is
independent of
this guy here and everything outside
but as i said that is too simplistic we
need to actually reveal the random coins
that are used to refresh we put them in
the crs
so now you cannot say the noise is fresh
it is actually not fresh it depends on
this random coins
right and now actually let's look at how
we concretely implement this id
we refreshing is just
adding or subtracting it's the same
thing an encryption of zero
right technically this is an extra noisy
encryption so these encryptions
use these as a randomness some kind of
noise
it's a lattice based you should not be
too surprised i guess and
this is a much higher magnitude noise
and the resulting ciphertext
is going to be under the randomness of
the original evaluated ciphertext
minus this so this is a randomness of
officer okay
so so far uh this is not fresh
right it depends on the function that
has been evaluated on it which i call fi
so we don't want that so we use the
circuit privacy
property of the fhe
which says that essentially you can make
this guy this
uh this thing fresh
at the price of making this thing not
fresh
you can move around the problem right
you cannot
completely erase this all the circular
issues that are common
right but you can you can locally you
can at least make
uh this effect fresh which means this
thing
will not be fresh because it depends on
on this but it will be
independent from uh the crafted smudging
noise
which is exactly what we want okay so
now this part is good
as far as good we have to take care of
that part
and if you look at it right you will
notice maybe that
this looks exactly like an essential
radiation it is actually
right it's an evaluated randomness
padded with some fresh randomness
this should be an encryption of zero it
is you can generate this guy from an
encryption of zero it doesn't really
matter how
so trust me this is just an srl linkage
so this is how you conclude the proof
by using srl circular security
all right a so
right the conclusion is uh the result
again
io from lwe and by the way because we
need smudging
not too surprisingly we need some
exponential modulus to no direction
all right and we use a strong circular
security conjecture which has some uh
quantitative difference with the
circular conjunctive
i use conjecture but think of it as
heuristic that we are used to
it's quite positive different and it's
with respect to this new sls security
and this uh well known scheme gsw and
backtracking
okay which both of them are secure and
the other movie
all right so originally actually what we
did is uh the same thing but we used
dumbbell turret
which is uh secure only
from a factorization style assumption
i mean decisional composite with uct
later on independently bdjm20b
uh and our ourselves we replace
essentially this
uh linear homomorphic encryption
so they use the back trigger uh sorry
pac dual regev and we use the pattern
gap encryption
at the level of details of my talk the
differences
between these two works are are uh
are not major they rely on a similar
type of assumption
right to key or key randomness cycle
okay
similar kind of circular srl assumption
all right
and then uh there's the work of
with the queen daniel weeks that you
will hear uh in a couple of minutes
which also has a circular flavor lies on
an assumption
uh known as obliviously something they
give up
uh security proof and there's this
assumption and they also give the
heuristic construction of this object
i mean i'm not gonna talk about it and
all of this work
they rely on the blueprint uh that julio
showed actually
this bdg m20a and they hinder it from
this
original construction the conceptual
simplicity
right there's no and finally this
is not this first work without gadget
but all of this other work
they are plausibly possible to secure
that's another advantage
and i'll conclude with a few words on
srl circular security but we already
actually
talked about this so it's a uh
so the heuristic is qualitatively
different and the slr security
assumption is qualitatively stronger
than the plain circular security
uh but we still think it's a natural
secret notion
which we can prove uh without key cycle
so uh the confidence we have is backed
up by a general design principle
all right so yeah that's it for me
thank you very much let me know if you
have questions if we have time
thank you thank you we do have a little
bit of time for the
questions and so are there any questions
and yes i see according to the
um yeah
uh so so according to the schedule i
think uh
daniel you talk uh
only needs to start at a 12 15
um 12 15 but
pacific but we could start it maybe a
little bit earlier if you wanted
just to be more on the safe side
either way it's okay uh there should be
enough time if we started uh
okay um yeah um
just in case i guess people uh saw the
schedule ahead of time or want to come
yes so we can stick with the original
schedule yes
yes i'm not completely sure uh yeah i
think i um i might have screwed up a
little bit with the schedule i didn't uh
i think i didn't in that this particular
break to be that large but uh
maybe it's a good thing we all could use
a break so
uh so we can meet up at the
12 15 at 12 15
on the pacific which is 3 15
eastern
thank